عميل بريطاني ابن عميل بريطاني لكن الفرق
بينهما كبير فالاب مخلص لبلده والابن خائن
وشيوعي حتى النخاع انه كمفيلبي احد اهم
جواسيس الحرب البارده بل قد يكاد يكون
الاهم بين فريق خماسيه جواسيس
الاكثر شهره فما قصته
ولد هارولد ادريان راسل المعروف بكينفيلبي
عام
1912 في امبالا بالهند وهو ابن الجاسوس
البريطاني جون فيلبي وقد تركه والده مع
والدته وانقطع عنهم في مهمه طويله
بالسعوديه بعد انهائه الثانويه التحق كيم
بجامعه
حيث اعجب بالفكر الشيوعي وانضم لعملاء
الاتحاد السوفيتي بشكل رسمي عام 1933
في البدايه انضم كيم للجنه مساعده الفارين
من الفاشيه النازيه في النمسا التي كانت
طريقه ليصبح جزءا من الكي جي بي حيث كان
احد خمسه طلاب اصبحوا عملاء لموسكو وعرفوا
باسم خماسيه كامبريد لكنه كان الاشهر
والاقدر على التخفي وتخطي المخاطر وخداع
الاستخبارات البريطانيه ومنهم والده
في بدايه تجنيده نقل كم الى اسبانيا للعمل
كصحفي حربي حتى عام 1940 وضمن خطه محكمه
قام العميل المزدوج جاي بورجس بتجنيده
بالمخابرات البريطانيه ثم ارسل الى واشنطن
في عام
1949 ليعمل رئيس ضباط الام اي 6 هناك
وكضابط اتصال بين جهازي المخابرات
البريطانيه والامريكيه خلال تلك الفتره
تسبب اكتشاف عدد من العملاء الغربيين لدى
السوفييت حيث اعتقل بعضهم وتم التصفيه
البعض الاخر كما كشف كيم للاتحاد السوفيتي
عن خطه للحلفاء لارسال عصابات مسلحه
مناهضه للشيوعيه الى البانيا في عام 1950
مما اكد هزيمتهم اما الشعره التي قسمت ظهر
البعير فكانت عندما حذر كيم العميلين
المزدوجين
من انهما محل شك وبالتالي هرب الرجلان الى
الاتحاد السوفيتي في عام
1951 فتم التحقيق معه لكن شيئا لم يثبت
عليه ثم في المره التاليه قدم العميل
التركي لدى احمد
المعادي لكنه هرب مجددا من التحقيق
واستقال خوفا من اكتشافه في عام
1955 اعلن وزير الخارجيه البريطاني هارولد
ماكملان ان كيم ليس خائنا فعاد الى جهاز
الاستخبارات من موقع اخر كل فكه بمهمه تحت
غطاء عمل صحافي كمراسل للاوبزيرفير في
بيروت قيل ان من بينها التجسس على والده
الذي كان قد بدا حياه جديده هناك بعد ان
اسلم وتزوج من سيده سعوديه واصبح اسمه
الشيخ عبد الله في عام 19
اخبرت صديقه قديمه ضابطه لاستخبارات
البريطاني فيكتور روتشلد ان كيم عرض عليها
العمل مع السوفيتي بالسابق كما كان قد وشى
به الضابط المنشق من الكي جي بي انا تولي
جولني في يناير من العام
1963 كلفت الاستخبارات البريطانيه نيكولاس
اليوت الذي كان صديقا لكيمب الانتقال الى
بيروت للتحقيق مع كم اعترف كيملينيكولاس
بعمالته ووعد بتسليمه اسماء عملاء مزدوجين
داخل انجلترا لكن الكي جي بي نجحت في
تهريب قبل اللقاء المنتظر على متن سفينه
تجاريه في مرفا بيروت في موسكو تابع كيم
وظيفته وحصل في النهايه على رتبه عقيد في
جهاز المخابرات السوفيتيه كما نشر كتابا
بعنوان ماي سايلنت وور يشرح تفاصيل حياته
توفي فيلبي في الحادي عشر من مايو عام
1988 في موسكو وعلى عكس والده الذي دفن
ببيروت مع جنازه متواضعه دفن رفات كيم في
مقبره كنتسيفو بوداع يليق برجل خدم
الاتحاد السوفيتي بكل اخلاص على مدى 35
عاما كما رويت قصته في كتاب للكاتب الشهير
بن ماكينتاير وتم انتاجه كفلم حمل الكتاب
اسم جاسوس بين الاصدقاء